if you're one of those people that are
like Tyson fur is just going to outclass
him this is stupid I'm not going to pay
for this I get all that but the one
thing that makes this different than a
Conor vers Floyd Logan Paul vers Floyd
if Tyson Fury for whatever reason
decides to take his eye off the prize if
he takes one nanc off in that fight and
Francis happens to land a left hook an
uppercut a right hand whatever it is
that fight is over over that's why
you're paying for this fight is he going
to outbox Tyson Fury not a chance but is
there a possibility at a plus 700 he can
land an uppercut a left hook a right
hand in a frenzy there's a chance and I
want to be part of that I'm GNA be
watching it